[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP je suis
heureuse de vous retrouver pour une
émission aux odeurs de sable chaud et de
Grand Large ce mois-ci à la veille des
grandes vacances nous nous intéressons
au tourisme et plus précisément au
tourisme de masse ça nous aura pas
échappé nous n'avons jamais autant
voyager raphaelettier oui en 2019 un
milliard 500 millions de personnes ont
fait du tourisme sur cette planète c'est
60 fois plus que dans les années 50 et
sur ce laps de temps les retombées
économiques du voyage et des vacances a
été multiplié par 600 autant dire que
les voyages font toujours autant rêver
plus que jamais recettes la France et
même la première destination touristique
au monde celle bémol et les deux tailles
le tourisme est à lui seul responsable
de 8% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans le monde au fait maman j'ai
arrêté l'avion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partout d'abord à Marseille ou un vent
d'hostilité c'est levé contre les
bateaux de croisière des mastodontes qui
peuvent accueillir jusqu'à 9000
passagers mais dans l'omniprésence
exaspère les riverains ces villes
flottantes sont accusées de cracher leur
fumée nuts et jours au mépris de
l'environnement et de la santé des
habitants pour la première fois la
justice a été saisie pour mise en danger
d'autrui et que Sid et pollution marine
le tout oposse est un sujet de Alexis
breton jawharnadi et Ibar
[Musique]
le vieux port de Marseille en début
d'après-midi un groupe de touristes
vient de débarquer et attend patiemment
le car qui va les faire visiter
vous avez combien de temps pour visiter
la ville
nous sommes là jusqu'à 17 heures et
après on rentre
c'est visiteurs sont ce que l'on appelle
des croisiersistes depuis Savone dans le
nord de l'Italie ils ont embarqué sur un
paquebot gigantesque vers Barcelone puis
Marseille
on a quatre jours pour tout faire
fini on rentre à Savone
[Musique]
c'est une mini croisière
Marseille accueille de plus en plus de
touristes comme eux
1,8 millions chaque année la ville est
la première destination des paquebots en
France
nous ne serions jamais venus à Marseille
sans les croisières on connaissait Nice
oui ni son connaît mais nous ne sommes
jamais venus à Marseille
c'est beau les croisiéristes n'ont rien
à préparer pour 300 euros par personne
et par ces jours le Tour Operator
s'occupe de tout visite sans sortir du
car audioguide sur les oreilles c'est
beau et quelques points de chute les
plus connus
[Musique]
on n'a pas à réfléchir en croisière on
quitte sa maison pour voir de très
belles choses tout est programmé c'est
super
les croisières le symbole du tourisme de
masse pour eux c'est l'occasion de
voyager pour pas cher mais pour certains
habitants ces bateaux géants sont un
cauchemar
dans le monde près de 500 bateaux de
croisière navigue sur toutes les mers de
plus en plus nombreux et de plus en plus
gros
certains peuvent accueillir jusqu'à 9000
passagers qui vivent dans un centre
commercial Géant ici une piste de
karting sur le bateau
là une salle de spectacle un spot de
surf une tyrolienne des dizaines de bars
et de restaurants
et des stars embauchées pour en faire la
pub Shakira ou Pénélope Cruz souris aux
lèvres et en tenue légère
[Musique]
mais ces monstres marins rejettent des
quantités phénoménales de gaz à effet de
serre et de polluants atmosphérique en
un an un seul paquebot émet autant de
CO2 que 10 000 voitures
par ailleurs il se rendent responsable
d'accidents parfois spectaculaire
au point que Venise leur a interdit
l'accès au centre historique et d'autres
villes y réfléchissent
[Musique]
loisir qui détruit la planète pour les
uns source de plaisir et de
développement économique pour les autres
deux visions s'opposent
d'un côté Christophe Castaner ancien
ministre et président du Grand port
maritime de Marseille de l'autre Fanny
pointait de l'ONG écologiste Transport
et Environnement
les bateaux de croisière avec tout le
reste c'est environ 3% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre au niveau mondial
donc c'est autant que l'aviation donc en
fait c'est un problème majeur pour le
climat aujourd'hui moi je reste
quelqu'un qui croit dans l'hédonisme et
je sais l'importance des croisières
c'est le voyage d'exception des classes
moyennes dans notre pays parce que c'est
un voyage d'exception qui n'est pas
forcément cher qui est abordable
non loin du vieux port de Marseille
quelques membres de stop croisière sont
rassemblés
[Musique]
ce collectif de riverain crée l'année
dernière s'est fait connaître grâce à un
coup d'éclat avec 12 kayaks les
militants sont parvenus à bloquer
pendant deux heures l'entrée dans le
port de l'un des plus gros paquebots du
monde
[Musique]
depuis ils ont déposé plainte contre X
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
pollution marine et Écaussinnes
et on comprend pas donc maintenant on
comprend pourquoi
nous sommes à l'Estaque au nord de la
ville
chantal est l'une des membres de stop
croisière elle vit depuis 32 ans dans ce
quartier populaire avec vue sur le
chantier naval il y en a toute l'année
vraiment
un petit peu moins l'hiver bien
évidemment mais on en a toute l'année et
là encore c'est un petit bateau qu'on
voit en fait il est minuscule celui-là
par rapport à quand il y a les bateaux
de croisière on voit plus les îles du
Frioul en fait tellement c'est
monstrueux
mais ces gros navires seraient
responsables d'après Chantal d'autres
nuisances bien plus graves
je me réveille quand même quasiment tous
les jours avec une sensation de gueule
de bois j'ai le foie enfin le système
hépatique un peu fragile donc j'ai du
mal à évacuer les toxines
donc ça c'est une des premières choses
ce qui génère des maux de tête des
nausées une sensation de grande fatigue
les yeux qui piquent enfin c'est des
symptômes assez commun aux gens qui
m'entourent quoi enfin aux gens qui
entourent le port autonome en fait à
partir de quand vous avez commencé à
avoir des problèmes de santé je dirais
depuis qu'il y a de plus en plus de
trafic maritimes à Marseille
c'est-à-dire ça correspond à une dizaine
d'années et très renforcée depuis je
sais pas je dirais quatre cinq ans
aujourd'hui aucune preuve ne permet de
lier les symptômes de Chantal au
paquebot de croisière en revanche selon
santé publique France la pollution de
l'air est responsable de 40000 décès
prématurés par an notamment à cause des
particules fines
les bateaux de croisière ce sont les
types de bateaux les plus émissifs et il
navigue près d'Echo donc en fait ils ont
un impact sur la qualité de l'air qu'on
respire directement c'est
essentiellement lié au rejet de
polluants atmosphérique que sont les
oxydes de soufre les oxydes d'azote et
les particules fines et tout ça en fait
ça crée des problèmes respiratoires des
maladies cardiovasculaires et des morts
prématurées chaque année
avec ses voisins chantal a installé un
capteur pour mesurer le taux de
particules fines dans l'air
chaque jour elle consulte les résultats
là on voit que hier à midi avec des pics
aujourd'hui on voit qu'avec le mistral
c'est plus tranquille quoi tout ce qui
dépasse les pointillés en fait on est on
est au dessus des pollutions tolérées
quoi donc on voit quand même qu'on
dépasse souvent
[Musique]
une semaine après notre tournage Chantal
nous a envoyé cette vidéo qu'elle a
filmé depuis la rue située juste devant
chez elle à l'image on distingue cinq
paquebots de croisière qui stationnent
dans le port une situation habituelle en
haute saison
à la date de la vidéo les émissions de
particules fines atteignent des records
la moyenne du week-end se situe à 23,9
microgrammes par mètre cube 1,5 fois
plus que la norme fixée par
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
le 14 mai un pic atteint même les 75
microgrammes par mètre cube soit 5 fois
plus que la norme internationale une
pollution dangereuse mais le port de
Marseille pense avoir trouvé la solution
au problème
nous avons rendez-vous avec Sophie Rouen
qui dirige le département voyageur
énergie au sein du Grand port maritime
de Marseille
donc là on est à l'intérieur du terminal
croisière c'est un terminal qu'on a
prévu d'équiper l'échéance 2025 de
connexion électrique mais dans ce
terminal on voit aussi produire de
l'électricité photovoltaïque sur ses
anciens
d'électrifier finalement en fait ici en
fait tous les navires historiquement
utilisent leur propre moteur dans les
ports pour avoir de l'électricité à bord
et quand on a comme ça beaucoup de
passage à bord on a besoin de beaucoup
d'électricité et donc ils utilisent
aujourd'hui leur groupe électrogène
interne qui sont à la fois des sources
de pollution puisqu'il brûle du diesel
et aussi ça produit du CO2 et donc des
gaz à effet de serre et donc ce qu'on
propose à son navire c'est de remplacer
leur groupe électrogène par une
connexion électrique pour le coup ne
produit pas de polluants et permet de
décarboner
aujourd'hui le port de Marseille et le
premier port de la Méditerranée en
matière d'électrification nous avons
déjà électrifié hacker la totalité des
bateaux de passagers qui vont vers la
Corse au mois de juin de cette année
c'est l'ensemble des séries qui vont
vers les pays du nord de l'Afrique et
l'Algérie en particulier et nous
commençons à investir massivement c'est
un programme de 50 millions d'euros en
tout pour électrifier les quais qui
accueille les croisières d'ici 2025 le
branchement Acquier ça va demander
d'énormes quantités d'énergie
disponibles donc c'est vraiment une
transition qui doit être prise en compte
par tous les opérateurs économiques par
les villes pour pouvoir donner
suffisamment de courant à ses navires
sans poser de problème on va dire pour
fournir de l'électricité à la ville donc
ça ça va demander quand même des
investissements colossaux pour les ports
d'après le port de Marseille les travaux
sont financés à 100% par de l'argent
public à partir de 2025 deux paquebots
pourront se brancher simultanément sur
le quai mais si d'autres accostent au
même moment ils devront continuer à
laisser tourner leur moteur en
permanence la pollution de l'air ne
diminuera donc qu'en partie
du côté des défenseurs des croisières on
préfère mettre en avant les bienfaits de
ces bateaux pour Marseille
allez on y va Jean-François suas est un
pilote
dont le travail est d'aider les gros
navires à accoster
il est également le président du club de
la croisière de Marseille qui milite
pour le développement de cette industrie
dans la ville
la croisière c'est une histoire qu'à peu
près 25 ans aujourd'hui les premiers
bateaux on va dire il y avait en gros on
dit toujours une cinquantaine escale à
20 000 passagers dans les années au
début des années 2000 on va dire la fin
des années 90 et aujourd'hui donc à 23
ans après on est plutôt à 2 millions et
à 600 escales des touristes qui ont
forcément selon lui un impact positif
sur l'économie de la ville
on avait 5000 personnes sur un bateau
mais ils vont se déplacer dans la vie
utiliser les transports communs utiliser
des taxis utiliser se rendre dans les
commerces dans le musée qui est derrière
etc et donc quand vous avez la chance
quand vous amène je crois 300 ou 400 000
Américains qui ne seraient jamais venus
à Marseille avec un bateau et qui vont
passer la journée dans Marseille je
crois que ça mérite d'avoir un regard
dessus alors un regard critique sans nul
doute mais un regard aussi bienveillant
parce que ce sont des gens qui voyagent
qui ont envie de découvrir notre culture
mais sur l'ensemble du territoire ce que
nous savons c'est que les croisières
génèrent à peu près entre 300 et 400
millions d'euros de retombées et on
emploie direct et indirect c'est près de
2400 emplois qui sont directement
impactés par l'activité croisière allez
sur le Vieux-Port et interroger les
riverains de l'Estaque mais aussi les
restaurateurs du Vieux Port ils vous
diront l'importance quand il y a des
arrivées de bateau de croisière il le
voit immédiatement
et bien c'est ce que nous avons fait
suivant les conseils de Christophe
Castaner nous nous sommes rendus dans le
panier l'un des quartiers les plus
touristiques de la ville
Lucas volmy un vendeur de vin est membre
du collectif top croisière nous
accompagne faire le tour des commerçants
beaucoup ne profitent pas des centaines
de milliers de croisiersistes qui
passent chaque année trois iris à chaque
fois ce qui me disent quand il rentre
dans la boutique parce qu'ils sont
évidemment attirés c'est des bijoux
c'est du corail mais ils me disent
toujours on n'a pas le temps il faut
qu'on y aille si les grands bateaux
étaient pas là est-ce que ça aurait une
différence pour votre commerce
même chose chez les voisins cavistes
sur les bateaux
règle strictes manque de temps les
croiseréristes ont également tout à
disposition sur leur bateau les
souvenirs à la nourriture résultat à
Marseille ce sont les commerçants qui
vendent des petits objets pas chers qui
s'en sortent le mieux ici des navettes
des biscuits à la fleur d'oranger
bonjour vous voulez savoir si est-ce que
vous recevez des Croisiers rustes ici
alors oui
on va dire significatif en nombre de
nombre de personnes parce que d'un coup
on va se retrouver avec 50 personnes
dans notre toute petite boutique mais
sur le moment ça nous ramène pas un
chiffre significatif non plus
concrètement économiquement oui c'est
sûr qu'on est mieux avec que ça
sacrifie beaucoup notre santé pour un
bénéfice économique qui est très
discutable il y en a certainement un
petit peu mais c'est vraiment mineur et
je vois pas pourquoi les Marseillais
devraient vendre leur santé pour ça
malgré l'opposition de la mairie de
Marseille le Port Autonome ne semble pas
vouloir diminuer ou limiter la
fréquentation des paquebots de croisière
l'activité de
croisière donc au même titre que
n'importe quel autre activité économique
elle doit se décarboner et le plus
rapidement possible vraiment la
condition sinequanone pour que cette
activité continue d'exister aujourd'hui
vous avez des gens qui sont globalement
contre les loisirs et au fond les
loisirs ce serait mal la piscine c'est
mal les croisières c'est mal le ski
c'est mal et je trouve que
cette espèce de revendication sanction
permanente contre tous ceux qui relèvent
de ce qui n'est pas utile ou de ce qui
n'est pas obligatoire
est une vraie menace même d'un point de
vue sociologique ça il y a de nombreuses
choses dont on peut considérer qu'elles
ne sont pas utiles la lecture la radio
la culture la musique le sport chacun
peut avoir son avis je pense que tout ça
est utile surtout au nom des libertés
individuelles de chacun
vous êtes d'accord avec Christophe
Castaner au nom des libertés
individuelles les loisirs sont un droit
inaliénable quoi qu'il en coûte pas du
tout moi je trouve que c'est très
caricatural comme point de vue puisque
tout est dit lorsqu'il parle des données
en fait c'est vrai qu'on assiste à une
transformation de ces dernières années
entre un tourisme éducatif c'est un peu
l'origine du tourisme et un tourisme
récréatif et ça c'est un petit peu
compliqué parce que on entre vraiment
dans la découverte artificielle des
territoires c'est ça le problème de
cette vision du tourisme
économique
Monsieur le Maire a complètement raison
moi je suis voyageiste je suis un fou de
voyage je suis un fou de dédonisme du
voyage et je suis désolé de dire qu'il
dit un peu n'importe quoi là c'est à
dire que
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi s'il y
a des conséquences pour les tiers les
habitants la planète l'écologie
bien sûr que le voyage est fantastique
mais avec des discours comme ça on va
finir par tuer le voyage c'est ça le
problème il y a des choses qui sont pas
acceptables
c'est il faut consommer du voyage à
n'importe quel prix moi je suis désolé
c'est NON au prix de la santé des gens
et là il y a une dame qui vit dans votre
portage qui est assez fou elle dit on
n'a pas réfléchi on est dans le bateau
on n'a pas réfléchir et c'est là la dure
réalité du réalité c'est qu'on vend une
image totalement
idyllique vous voyez il y a même j'ai la
première fois merci pour votre reportage
je vois qu'il y avait des courses de
cartes voilà c'est quand même assez
dingue derrière et moi je l'ai dit en
tant que président de la Commission de
transport et tourisme là j'ai un
problème de fond parce qu'il y a double
impact c'est de montrer aux yeux de tous
la grande absurdité du tourisme des
mesurer et je suis sûr que vous avez
comme d'accord avec moi
et la deuxième chose c'est la santé des
gens en fait là on parle d'oxyde d'azote
est-ce qu'on a des des particules
absolument au niveau européen transport
maritime c'est directement 60 000 morts
prématurés mais c'est le coup qui doit
nous faire réfléchir en tout cas on
parle de 58 milliards
milliards d'euros je pense qu'on peut
faire autre chose ça c'est la première
chose
alors une plante a été déposée pour
effectivement était bien signé un lien
de causalité entre les pollutions
générées et les symptômes recensés en
attendant à l'étranger plusieurs villes
notamment le centre historique de Venise
mais aussi Palma des Majorque ont pris
des mesures radicales et interdit les
paquebots est-ce qu'il faut réguler de
cette manière là absolument va attendre
les drames pourquoi Venise un moment
décide d'interdire faut souvenir de
cette image extraordinaire de ce giga
paquebot vous l'appelez comment vous
voulez qui arrive aux portes de Venise
et qui manquent d'arracher notamment
cette fameuse jetée qui est
extraordinaire et là ça a été le signal
d'alarme ou là les les populations dit
ça suffit
là où les Croisiers risques se rendent
pas compte et l'industrie du voyage en
général c'est qu'en fait il tue leur
propre produit mais les premiers
responsables quand même je voudrais le
dire c'est les clients
les clients qui achètent ça je voudrais
quand même dire que les croisières alors
elles ont beaucoup beaucoup de défauts
moi personnellement c'est pas du tout
mon truc on en vend d'ailleurs pas du
tout chez Voyageurs du Monde mais ça a
quand même quelques qualités ça permet
aux gens de pas changer d'hôtel tous les
soirs les personnes âgées adorent ça ça
pourrait très bien par exemple si vous
circulez si vous changez de de de de de
d'énergie de propulsion évidemment
l'hydrogène verte et l'idéal vous croyez
vraiment au carburant vert pour bien sûr
vous pensez vraiment que la technologie
va sauver le secteur prenons prenons
l'exemple du biogaz ou le gaz il y a des
bateaux des gros bateaux de croisière
qui sont qui commencent à circuler au
biogaz alors c'est pas parfait mais ça
divise par deux les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre déjà un premier point et
puis cette année pas carrément me
contredira si j'ai une bêtise moi je
veux contredire
le GL produit effectivement 20 à 25% des
missions de CO2 en moins que le fioul
lourd mais il est en majeur parti
composé de méthane dont l'effet de serre
est beaucoup plus élevée alors peut-être
dans ce cas-là
ça n'a rien à voir mais ça reste moi je
pense
et puis le le truc idéal ça serait
l'hydrogène vert évidemment alors là
vous êtes tranquille parce que les
bateaux ça a cette capacité à pouvoir
contrairement aux avions en mettre
autant de quantité que vous voulez en
termes de place et si vous produisez
d'hydrogène vert à base d'électricité
est là pour activer on est en train de
justement de mettre en place la
législation on est en train de dire tous
les bateaux quels qu'ils soient au
niveau européen vont devoir à partir de
2030 être à l'électrification hackée
parce que il y a l'impact sur les
populations
de la propulsion pendant le voyage alors
cela propose sur la propulsion sur le
voyage il y a aujourd'hui
des solutions hautes qui sont en train
d'arriver par exemple on a la chance
le problème c'est à nous de savoir parce
que par exemple l'alternative au moins
je dis l'alternative ou les alternatives
c'est par exemple le velik alors le
velik c'est notamment les bateaux à
voile aujourd'hui on a une capacité
industrielle extraordinaire à le faire
le problème que nous avons c'est que
malheureusement tout ça il va falloir le
reconvertir parce que c'est du fioul
lourd donc vous voyez que derrière il y
a toute une nouvelle industrie
d'économie circulaire qu'il faut mettre
en place former des salariés etc et
ensuite il faut se poser la question de
la cadence moi je suis désolé dans le
port de Marseille comment se fait-il
qu'on accorde 5 de croisière en même
temps et la dernière chose c'est la
question de la taille la taille des
voitures on n'est pas d'accord d'avoir
ces espèces de temps qui est sur nos
routes sur la mer c'est pareil un mot un
mot s'il vous plaît électrique la
question des quais
les travaux sont financés à 100% par
l'argent public certains regrettent que
les armateurs ne soient pas mis à
contribution selon le bon vieux principe
du pollueur-payeur qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Richard du moment où on développe
et quand je dis on se sont les
voyagistes c'est pas une critique
personnelle mais les opérateurs du
secteur ont développé de plus en plus la
destination de manière obsessionnelle on
veut vendre de la destination comme on
veut vendre des cartes postales on peut
pas en même temps vouloir proclamer la
protéger et être absolument certain
qu'on réussira la transition écologique
le problème du financement c'est qu'il
devrait être assuré exclusivement par
les armateurs et par les opérateurs
est-ce que est-ce c'est vraiment
discutable parce que à l'heure où l'on
demande aux Français Jean-François Rial
de faire des économies d'énergie de
faire des économies d'énergie on peut
s'étonner effectivement que l'argent
public servent à alimenter les pistes de
ski les patinoires ou les simulateurs de
surf c'est monstres que les armateurs
c'est une vraie question je dis que
ça dépend si on veut que on on si on
veut
décarboner l'économie tout azimut il
n'est pas complètement anormal que les
pouvoirs publics et les fonds publics y
participent à 100% non pas forcément à
100% mais pour pouvoir l'accélérer vous
savez nous on pénalise en Europe aux
États-Unis ils donnent des crédits
d'impôts pour que les gens des carbone
et ils vont plus vite que nous c'est un
problème voyez par exemple soit des
voies d'intérieur américain en 2050
c'est 100% de carburant de synthèse nous
on est encore en train de discuter un ou
deux pour cent à l'intérieur des
carburants de synthèse l'activité du
secteur de toute façon vous décarbonez
pas vous pouvez réduire changer la les
carburants
ce n'est pas vrai ce que vous dites je
suis désolé de vous dire si vous vous
décarbonez les jets privés moi je
propose que les jets privés soient
carburant de synthèse ça marche tout de
suite à 100 % eh ben je suis désolé
100 % Raphaël je connais mon sujet
100%. alors
produisait de l'électricité verte et que
vous en générer de l'hydrogène vert vous
allez décarboner à 95% la production
mais c'est pas grave bien sûr que si
bien sûr que si les moyens de production
si vous produisez tous l'électricité
je ne suis pas d'accord alors justement
d'entendre des âneries quand on me parle
de la production et qu'on dit qu'on peut
pas la décarboner c'est pas vrai si vous
si vous produisez avec de l'électricité
verte et si pour ça d'ailleurs que je
suis pour le nucléaire et que je
considère que je suis un écolo très
engagé je suis à 100 % pour le tenir
parce que si on veut des carboner la
seule vraie alternative c'est
l'électricité des carbonée voilà et donc
ils sont utilisés je partage une partie
2030 il n'est pas question d'avoir
réduit de 100%
2030 si vous reprenez les accords de
pareil vous mettez sur une ligne à 2
degrés parce que le 1 degrés et demi moi
j'adore c'est perdu voilà il faut
baisser de 20% et je suis désolé on peut
monter les trafics et baisser des
importants contrairement à ce que vous
dites j'aimerais bien montrer j'aimerais
bien entendre Richard
c'est pas la solution et sur les jet
privé vous les prenez aujourd'hui c'est
14 fois 14 toi plus en termes d'émission
que quand vous regardez 100% d'accord
il faut relancer le train le problème du
train en admettant que on est l'offre et
les connexions qu'on a pas mais on a le
message si vous remplacez tout ce que
vous pouvez remplacer vous allez réduire
de 10% les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pourquoi si carrément sur l'avion
parce que malheureusement le train va
vous remplacer du coup et du moyen
courrier hors le sujet c'est le long
courrier donc c'est pour ça que moi je
veux imposer le carburant de synthèse au
jet privé pour qu'il nous crée une
filière et que cette filière elle nous
permet de décarboner le long courrier
alors moi je pense trois trucs très vite
il faut absolument interdire tout ce que
l'alternative la convention citoyenne
disait lorsqu'elle alternative à 4
heures on y va ça il faut le faire
deuxième chose il faut que j'arrête la
France arrête de nous bloquer le texte
que nous travaillons sur le ciel unique
européen qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc
c'est on optimise des flux européens
pour les réduire moins 10% de CO2 au
niveau européen on est contre l'aviation
si on veut décarboner la viande avec
toutes les outils qu'on a si on
n'utilise pas de façon massive le
carburant de synthèse on y arrivera
s'il vous plaît Richard qui est votre
village gore dans la vie a été sacré
plus beau village au monde par ce
magazine américain certaines villes et
villages aujourd'hui refusent d'être
distinguées par crainte des hordes
incontrôlables d'autres font carrément
du démarketing comme les calanques de
Marseille ou l'île d'Aix pour décourager
les foules vous vous ne craignez pas la
surf fréquentation de Gordes
on la connaît déjà depuis une vingtaine
d'années et on avait déjà été distingués
par des labels comme plus beau village
de France ou des partenariats par
exemple avaient Netflix dans Émilie in
Paris ou autre où il y avait déjà été
l'impact de ce tournage sur sur Gordes
nous on a négocié avec Netflix donc
l'occupation des lieux et des parkings
donc ça a pas du tout été à somme nul
pour eux donc on a obtenu des sommes
financières importantes pour la commune
autrement il y a pas eu de difficultés
particulières liées à ce tournage mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est l'ambiguïté
quand même dans lequel on se trouve
lorsqu'on veut effectivement interdire
comme le font certains villages
carrément l'accès au village à Marseille
apporte pas loin ou encore on commence à
contingenter il faut par exemple
préserver trois jours à l'avance pour
admirer la calanque de sujiston dans
l'accès limité à 400 personnes ça ça ne
vous inspire pas c'est quelque chose
qu'on a demandé nous un certain des
opérateurs privés comme l'abbaye de
Sénanque d'ailleurs de prévoir un
système de réservation en amont
effectivement pour limiter notamment
dans leur géographiques voilà mais je
dirais que les exemples que vous donnez
sont des exemples où le tourisme de
masse s'est révélé destructeur comme
dans les calanques le tourisme à Gordes
ne pose pas ses problèmes là mais tout
est fait pour anticiper justement le
fait qu'il ne les pose pas assez soucis
ce que vous dites vrai mais il y a plein
de villes en Europe où les maires ont
pris des mesures un peu drastiques sympa
mais drastiques veut dire mais je pense
notamment aux maires Dubrovnik alors
nous revenus cité médiévale de Game of
Thrones tout le monde veut faire sa
petite photo etc sur des compteurs qui a
installé des compteurs à l'emploi donc
ils ont pris les règles de notamment de
l'ONU et ils ont dit pour l'autorise
durable il y a il y a un certain nombre
de touristes à accepter l'ONU dit sur
selon la surface etc c'est 8000
touristes eux ils ont dit 4000 les gens
qui doivent la question qu'on devrait se
poser c'est étonnons en capacité de
recevoir autant de monde nos
infrastructures suivent-elles et quel
est l'impact pour l'environnement est-ce
que ce sont des questions que vous vous
posez vous c'est une question qu'on se
pose tous les jours en lien avec les
services de l'État et par rapport à
l'État central en fait parce qu'en
réalité je vous donne l'exemple donc que
je connais sweet Gordes nous avons
effectivement pris d'un million de
visiteurs attendus cette année qui gère
ses flux on est même pas 15 personnes
pour accueillir un million de visiteurs
c'est d'ailleurs il y a 7 gendarmes deux
policiers municipaux et quelques
saisonniers et moi-même en tant que mère
et le local je suis amené parfois à
interpeller à verbaliser on se sent
parce qu'en réalité il suffirait de
changer certains éléments dans la
réglementation notamment nationale par
exemple pour arriver à des solutions je
vous donne un exemple typique vous avez
des panoramas qu'on vient photographier
il y a des encombrements il suffirait
qu'on nous autorise comme dans les
villes à adapter une verbalisation vidéo
parce qu'on a le droit de mettre de la
vidéo protection mais pas de la
verbalisation vidéo tout d'un coup ça
fluidifierait ou qu'on nous permet
d'adopter des amendes un petit peu
nouvelles plus dissuasifs que les 11
euros mais pourquoi ne pas envisager un
système de réservation en ligne un péage
à l'entrée du village ou une
piétonisation tout simplement les péages
c'est pour les eaux selon moi c'est à
dire qu'en fait on n'est pas un parc
d'attraction on n'est pas Disney Gordes
voilà donc avec un million avec un
million de touristes par an c'est d'être
en place des péages il faut avoir il
faut que ce soit une réflexion des
services de l'État qu'on est les outils
pour le faire rien ne nous permet nous
autorise à supprimer la liberté d'aller
venir par contre là où je suis
totalement d'accord c'est qu'il faudrait
réguler le taux le système touristique
et la sacro-sainte liberté d'aller
devenir qui a un rang const itutionnel
et international elle connaît déjà ses
limites pourquoi on peut constamment
aller et venir dans tous les coins du
globe et parfois de manière destructive
c'est ça le problème moi souvent je
regarde les Twitter de notre ami qui
sont très intéressants qui montrent des
dunes des paysages majestueux la
question c'est ce qu'ils sont faits pour
être justement montré par une société de
consommation spectaculaire ça c'est mon
sujet quand même
[Musique]
je vous donne la parole le tourisme de
masse il est sur concentration des sites
ces catastrophique c'est l'antithèse
totale ce qu'il faut faire dans le
voyage il faut avoir conscience que je
le dis souvent
95% de ceux qui voyagent vont sur 5% des
sites dans le monde et encore je pense
que je suis gentil
moi je pense qu'il faut appliquer tous
les systèmes de quota possible tous même
s'ils ne vont pas tout résoudre ils sont
plus faciles bien sûr sur un site type
Sénanque ou la Tour Eiffel que sur une
commune Le Mont-Saint-Michel c'est une
commune collongent enrouge c'est une
commune garde de Monsieur c'est une
commune moi je pense que là il faut
réfléchir à tous les systèmes qui
empêchent ça parce que
même avec des quotas même avec des
systèmes piétonniers vous êtes chez
Disney c'est plus possible c'est-à-dire
que vous flinguez l'authenticité de
votre produit vous flinguez l'âme de
l'endroit vous ennuyez les les gens des
villages ou des villes comme dubrovniko
à Barcelone récemment ce qu'on a vu ou
même à Paris à Paris à la Tour Eiffel ce
n'est plus possible moi je pars
touristique pour les gens se
répartissent il faut faire plein de
choses il faut faire plein de choses
d'abord il faut éduquer faut éduquer et
très fort pour que les clients arrêtent
de vouloir faire ça les clients
Voyageurs du Monde ne font pas ça les
plus riches
d'éducation de la planète quand même
donc
le prix des vacances
il faut éduquer tout le monde il faut
éduquer les clients il faut éduquer les
professionnels mes confrères qui
continue de programmer des tours moi je
le vois en tant que président d'office
de tourisme de Paris ce que me font mes
américains lorsqu’il programme pareil
mais moi j'hallucine et moi je veux
qu'on vende Paris autrement je veux
qu'on vende les quartiers où il y a
personne les quartiers il y a pas de
selfie etc etc troisième chose il faut
des des vendre sur faux réguler par la
loi il faut réguler et il faut étendre
les horaires il faut étendre les
horaires la Tour Eiffel moi je dis 24/24
et les riches ça va faire plaisir à
Karima ils vont y aller à 11h du soir
ils vont payer très cher ce qui
permettra de payer mieux les salariés et
d'avoir moins de masse la journée
Jean-François Rial vous parliez de cotta
on va écouter l'un un promoteur de quota
écoutez
l'idée que même on puisse prendre quatre
vols en avion dans une vie
il y a un gros demi-siècle ça n'existait
pas je veux dire pour la population dans
son ensemble donc ce truc qui paraît
aujourd'hui inconcevable restrictif
malthusien triste cirque casse-bonbon et
j'en passe à une partie des gens qui
réagissent il faut bien que il se
rendent compte que c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement récent et qui
partira avec le pétrole parce que quand
on regarde les alternatives techniques
au pétrole dans l'aviation de toute
façon une fois qu'il y aura plus de
pétrole il y aura pas de quoi assurer
quatre vols dans une vie par terrien il
y aura pas alors vous l'avez entendu
Jean-Marc jeancovici persiste à penser
qu'il faut des quotas de vol par
personne cette idée vous fait bondir
je connais beaucoup Jean je connais très
bien Jean-Marc j'ai beaucoup des signes
pour lui cette année écologiste qu'on
inclus il est brillant mais je suis en
désaccord complet c'est à dire qu'on
confond l'objectif et les moyens
l'objectif c'est de respecter les
accords du GIEC ça c'est incontournable
et moi je serai le premier à être
toujours le dire
il a décidé des moyens et moi je trouve
que son moyen est le pire parce que
c'est un système chinois c'est un
système de notes sociales qui va être
contourné où les riches vont plus
voyager que les autres parce que ça va
tricher etc allez vite je vais vous dire
un truc qui va vous choquer qui va
coucher avec tous mes confrères je
préférerais qu'on interdise l'avion que
son truc carrément alors qu'est-ce que
des billets
moi je pense qu'il y a
parce que c'est trop long
il y a 25 mesures qui permettent de
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de l'avion
optimisation des jeunes voyageurs du
monde entre 2019 et 2022
abaisser ses émissions globales sans
offset sans compensation sans absorption
que je fais en plus à bccélération de
30%. moitié effet nombre de clients
moitié effet optimisation des moteurs
etc etc sur sadem c'est pas mes chiffres
c'est bon voilà donc à la pandémie
peut-être non non
je vais en vous l'enlever la moitié sur
les 30 c'est l'effet clients l'autre
moitié c'est un chiffre d'affaires
constant en 2023 je vais faire plus de
chiffre d'affaires qu'en 2019 genre plus
de clients qu'en 2019 et je vais avoir
des émissions plus faibles d'au moins
10% bon donc il y a plein de choses les
routes le ciel est unique européen comme
l'a dit Karima les moteurs etc ça
suffira pas très clair et puis par
ailleurs il y a le trafic à faire qui
baisse donc moi je dis que la vraie
solution la vraie bonne et le train
évidemment tout ça mais la vraie grosse
solution c'est du carburants de synthèse
là on n'est pas d'accord avec Jean-Marc
c'est Jean-Marc qui dit c'est pas
possible à l'échelle bon moi je dis
c'est possible à l'échelle par contre il
y aura un conflit d'usage sur
l'électricité verte et ça oui ça je suis
d'accord mais d'ici 2050 on peut le
faire et moi ce que je dis c'est que
l'aérien doit baisser ses émissions
quelle que soit le volume y compris si
ça croit dans le cadre du GIEC et que je
suis complètement contre cette solution
à propos d'impact environnemental la
crème solaire dont on se tartine
abondamment toute la journée au soleil
n'est pas notre non plus Raphaël c'est
l'heure du climatoscope et c'est à vous
[Musique]
on disperse un petit nuage un petit
cocktail chimique autour de soi à chaque
fois avec quel impact alors l'impact le
mieux documenté c'est celui sur les sur
les sur les coraux on observe que ça
fait blanchir les coraux raison pour
laquelle Hawaï ils ont ils ont interdit
ils ont interdit l'usage de de ces
filtres organiques et toutes ces parties
d'une étude scientifique qui date de
2008 une équipe italienne qui a réussi à
montrer en faisant des tests tout
simplement avec des filtres organiques
quand vous rajoutez même en petite
quantité sur des coraux vous aviez un
phénomène de blanchiment et le mécanisme
est assez surprenant en fait c'est ces
molécules réactives les virus dormants
qui sont présents dans les algues qui
elles-mêmes sont en symbiose avec le le
corail une vie un petit peu compliqué
comme ça et bah c'est grave dans le sens
où les coraux sont ce qu'on appelle des
hotspots des points chauds de
biodiversité c'est là que se concentre
toute la vie marine et donc du coup à
chaque fois qu'un corail se meurt en
fait c'est toute la folle autour qui qui
trinque et du coup alors la crème n'est
pas responsable de tout
s'exposer non protégé c'est une usine à
cancer il faut choisir éventuellement
faire attention aux positions la crème
on est évitant possiblement les les
filtres organiques préférés les filtres
minéraux mais là encore ça commence à
monter on se demande si ça pose pas
d'autres d'autres problèmes il y a la
waterproof la résistante à l'eau ça
évite d'en mettre trop de tartiner des
coraux en même temps il y a une autre
dernière solution quand même c'est
d'aller maintenant il faut aller pas
passer ces vacances à l'ombre d'un grand
chêne dans le Berry par exemple
ou alors Gordes ou la densité
touristique autrement dit le nombre de
lits rapportés à la population et de
193% le village arrive en deuxième
position du top 10 de la fréquentation
touristique dans le département les les
villageois le vivent bien comme je vous
ai expliqué il y a 50 km2 donc en
réalité la visite touristique elle se
diffuse parfaitement bien dans les
hameaux dans cet univers de masse de
pierre sèche il y a pas de difficulté
majeures sur la commune de l'eau à la
mi-messe 5 bassins versants du Vaucluse
était en alerte renforcée alors que les
sécheresses se multiplient j'imagine que
la question de l'eau de son rationnement
est une vraie question non de toute
façon on a surconsommation d'eau c'est
l'une des plaies du tourisme de masse et
c'est évident que ça concerne gore de vu
le nombre de piscines que nous avons
dans les hôtels et l'Égypte elle est
l'étape d'hotes le vrai problème c'est
pourquoi là aussi nous n'avons pas les
moyens l'État ne donne pas les moyens
aux élus locaux d'intervenir réellement
parce que à partir du moment où on prend
des arrêtés pour dire qu'on ne doit pas
remplir les piscines il est évident
qu'il faut qu'on puisse les appliquer
nous arrêter et si vous pouvez pas avoir
aucun moyen de contrôle c'est un vœu
pieux ça ça fait aussi partie des
difficultés que nous rencontrons nous
les élus locaux l'autre difficulté
j'imagine ce sont les incendies le
Vaucluse est un département à très haut
risque d'incendie
oui c'est pour ça que c'est complètement
irresponsable comme le font certains
opérateurs de laisser déferler des
dizaines de milliers de touristes dans
des vallons comme l'abbaye de Sénanque
ou de créer des boucles vélo qui sont
complètement dangereuses en fait parce
que effectivement en cas de risque
incendie même si on y met le maximum de
moyenne d'effectifs de réservoir et tout
ce que vous voulez on n'arrivera pas au
risque zéro j'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi un moment vous vous dites pas
comme d'autres villes en Europe il faut
réduire le nombre de touristes parce que
on va pas pouvoir remplir toutes les
piscines parce que justement au niveau
des tours opérateurs et des offices de
tourisme nous c'est des risques de vous
programmer et qui vous leur disiez quels
sont les autres très beaux villages du
Lubéron sublime avoir et qu'on visite
tout seul plutôt que d'aller à Gordes
c'est exactement ça qu'on a fait puisque
avec les maires du canton on s'était
opposés c'est important de le dire à la
traduction des documents touristiques
locaux en chinois parce qu'effectivement
ça pose de vraies difficultés puisque la
Chine j'adore la Chine mais à partir du
moment où vous vous vendez une
destination à la Chine s'il y a que 0,1%
revient ça crée des problèmes et on a vu
tous ces images de chinois dans tous les
champs de lavande c'est très bien quand
ils sont une dizaine quand ils sont des
dizaine de milliers c'est plus possible
donc il faut savoir que le tourisme le
tourisme est une compétence le tourisme
est aujourd'hui une compétence
intercommunale alors quoi qu'il en soit
en France si on n'a pas de pétrole on a
des idées pour promouvoir un tourisme
alternatif et si possible régénératif
afin d'améliorer la destination plutôt
que de la défigurer l'hébergement de nos
vacances est responsable de 7% des
émissions de CO2 du tourisme certains
d'entre vous en sont conscients 40% des
Français se disent même prêt à payer
plus cher pour réduire leur impact
chiche une appli et à prise homo le
monde de demain commence aujourd'hui et
ça tombe bien il est apporté de train la
preuve par ce reportage signé Jaguar
Nadi
[Musique]
à Saint-Germain des essours en Normandie
au cœur d'une forêt privée de 27
hectares que l'on ne peut emprunter 4
pieds pour ne pas déranger la nature
voici Guillaume Jouffre et Jean-François
Turcan deux professionnels du tourisme
atypique donc là on a la première cabane
Jean-François est le propriétaire de
neuf cabanes comme celle-ci perchée dans
les arbres à plusieurs mètres du sol
[Musique]
c'est super
des nids pour humain qu'ils mettent en
location grâce à Guillaume le fondateur
d'une application dédiée au tourisme
écolo et dans le genre location non
polluante celle-ci est en haut de la
pyramide
[Musique]
donc là nous avons tout simplement le
petit coin toilette
on s'éclaire sans ça à la bougie
là on a le système de toilette sèche
ici la réserve dessus et puis on utilise
un système de sac compostable les
clients ont devoir l'enlever avant de
partir
150 euros par nuit tout de même pas
d'eau courante ni d'électricité mais
quelques bonnes surprises
la cerise sur le gâteau
sur la terrasse super
l'intérêt environnemental de ces
hébergements insolites c'est que c'est
le bon ratio entre une expérience
vraiment sympa et vraiment atypique et
vraiment dépaysante et un impact
environnemental très faible quoi donc
c'est ça sacoche vraiment voilà
et apparemment de plus en plus de
touristes sont intéressés Guillaume a
créé son application il y a deux ans il
proposait 50 locations au départ pour
plus de 6000 aujourd'hui
elles doivent répondre à 113 critères
écologiques émission de CO2 recyclage
utilisation de l'eau et de l'énergie ou
accessibilité
Jean-François bah voilà il est
compatible sans voiture c'est à dire
peut venir chez Jean-François
directement passer une gare pas loin que
Jean-François peut aller vous chercher à
la gare on s'est aperçu qu'en fait on
pouvait prendre autant de plaisir en
voyageant et en ayant un impact vraiment
dérisoire par rapport à les voyages
qu'on avait peut-être l'habitude de
faire dans le passé et on essaye de
créer les ingrédients techniques avec
notre site mais aussi voilà l'imaginaire
etc pour pour rendre ça possible
concrètement et donc du côté des
solutions aussi il s'agit pas juste de
parler de problème mais nous on essaye
de construire les solutions pour pour
rendre ce tourisme agréable
[Musique]
quant aux clients ils sont forcément
sensibles autant au lieu que la démarche
flore et Lucas sont tous les deux
fonctionnaires très préoccupés par les
questions environnementales ils sont
arrivés le matin de Paris en train pour
les vacances on prend plus l'avion
en tout cas toutes les destinations qui
sont accessibles et toutes les vacances
qu'on fait en l'occurrence en Europe on
privilégie le train il y a pas besoin de
choses très compliquées qu'on peut faire
des choisir des destinations simples des
modes de voyage plus simple et il faut
pas forcément se dire que parce que on
va aller à l'autre bout de la planète on
va complètement se déconnecter du reste
il y a pas besoin de ça en fait
une autre manière d'envisager le
tourisme que les défenseurs des voyages
propres tentent de rendre attractives
alors que le secteur en pleine expansion
représente déjà au niveau mondial 8% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
Jean-François ayal vous voyez qu'en pas
besoin de partir loin pour déconnecter
le besoin tourisme durable existe
d'ailleurs moi voyez par exemple je ne
voyais jamais à l'étranger l'été parce
que je considère que c'est le pire
moment pour voyager je profite de mon
Cantal le voyage oui non mais même des
pièges voyage pas je voyage pas est-ce
que vous avez proposé des voyages à pied
à vélo
on fait énormément
de voyage comme ça on en vend énormément
ça fait des années qu'on te propose en
vélo et à pied en France mais voyez dire
que le tourisme local empêche le
tourisme de masse c'est pareil là dans
le reportage qui est assez je pense
intéressant c'est de revenir sur ce que
moi j'appelle excusez moi du mot
l'exotisme en bas de chez soi
c'est-à-dire on n'a pas besoin d'être à
l'autre bout de la terre pour découvrir
notre territoire il y a des choses
extraordinaires les Français ont
découvert des choses incroyables comme
les Européens après le covid on a des
touristes de demain sera un temps
régional je bah il peut être
interrégional mais il faut que tout le
monde ait le choix et l'accessibilité
parce que je regarde votre 150 euros 50
euros la nuit moi je viens du Nord les
populations tout le monde bah beaucoup
peuvent pas partir en vacances donc les
150 euros ce serait pour personne voilà
et d'autres 300 euros alors qu'est-ce
qu'on propose à ces populations pour
rêver parce qu'elles ont aussi le droit
d'être rêvé et ben nous on a mis en
place et je suis contente ça dure depuis
des années mais le train 1 € pour aller
voir la mer même une journée vous voyez
ça et moi je porte alors je suis
contente de le redire je porte à
l'échelle française que j'appelle le
ticket de climat c'est à dire par an par
mois pardon de quelques 40 50 euros pour
découvrir partout la France prendre
quand on veut le train notamment le TER
pour dire le train oui c'est la clé
d'entrée pour le climat pour donc pour
découvrir nos territoires réconciliés
nos territoires parce que la fracture
territoriale est très forte en France et
la troisième chose on peut redonner goût
à des emplois de demain et notamment le
tourisme local ça va être les et c'est
ça qui va falloir préparer et je suis
sûr qu'on va travailler ensemble sur ça
quelles vont être les métiers du
tourisme local et durable moi j'aimerais
vous poser une question la solution
radicale finalement pour diminuer son
empreinte carbone serait peut-être de
voyager tout en restant dans son canapé
les spécialistes de la réalité virtuelle
vont bien compris et elle propose déjà
mélanger je vous le pose déjà des
voyages de rêve du voyage déjà de voyage
là pour moi
justement je vous pose la question parce
que vous savez Pompéi Pompéi ne se
visite plus une situe mais bientôt je
visitera en réalité virtuelle
qu'il faut protéger donc faut empêcher
les visiteurs donc des visites
virtuelles peuvent se justifier mais
alors moi j'ai moi j'ai vu il y a 10 ans
arriver chez voyageur du monde des gens
qui m'ont proposé des visites virtuelles
de safari en Namibie ou Botswana je leur
ai demandé gentiment de repartir quoi
c'est épouvantable vous allez peut-être
être d'accord avec moi pour une le
voyage c'est la rencontre c'est l'âme
c'est la spiritualité c'est la connexion
avec l'épine Jean-François vous allez
peut-être d'accord avec moi on le
répétera jamais assez le passé est un
bon indicateur pour comprendre l'avenir
vous êtes d'accord avec ça
pas toujours parfois oui parfois non
comme chaque mois l'histoire comme
chaque fois Charlotte et PAL est allé
fouiller dans les archives de Lina et
nous a exhumé ceci il y a encore sur
notre coup d'oeil dans le rétro et c'est
maintenant
sur les berges du canal du Rhône assez
La Grande-Motte apporte aux visiteurs
une curieuse impression de dépaysement
nous nous trouvons ici dans la main ce
bande de terre comprise entre les temps
de Mauguio et la mer
partons calme et soleil c'est un pays de
grands silence dont le cœur bat sonâtre
au fil des plaisirs et des joues mais
qui pourrait penser que ces modestes
cabanes vont bientôt s'effacer devant un
aménagement touristique d'envergure ce
n'est donc pas en vain que le mot
Guillaume s'est appelé aussi étant de
l'homme la Grande-Motte sera demain
aussi couru que les stations balnéaires
les plus célèbres de la Côte d'Azur
chevaux est taureau plaque les accords
blancs et noirs de leur insouciante
liberté dans cette nature indomptée qui
respire toujours du souffle large de
Calendal
voici des images qui parlent un langage
de tradition et de quiétude pêcheurs et
chasseurs demeurent les rois de cette
chaussée virgilienne sur laquelle le
progrès ne s'est point encore avancé le
pasteur cher avait à Rennes y est une
accorde passeuse et les nouvelles
quotidiennes n'arrivent pas à troubler
la flânerie paresseuse des canards
le temps que Proust croyait perdu prend
à La Grande-Motte ses vacances
la Grande Motte d'avant le béton c'était
j'imagine le bon temps absolument et on
a vu que justement le progrès cette
construire construire et bétonner
bétonné mais aujourd'hui regardez ce
qu'il en est c'est aussi l'altération
des sites naturels qui est l'une des
pathologies les plus importantes du
tourisme de masse nous allons nous
quitter sur ces mots mais avant de vous
quitter et avant de nous quitter je vous
laisse en excellente compagnie avec la
jeune et très très talentueuse comme
Étienne notre échoactiviste préféré a
beaucoup de choses à nous dire elle n'y
va pas par quatre chemins c'est l'heure
de sa carte verte
alors maman j'ai raté l'avion et c'est
peut-être la meilleure chose que je nous
souhaite en réalité à nous d'arriver en
retard d'arriver en retard à cette
course effrénée qui n'a ni fin ni
finalité je vous souhaite d'arriver en
retard à ce rendez-vous qui nous
condamne dorer notre propre enterrement
en quelque sorte et notre salut se
trouve lui dans l'atterrissage alors
pour toutes ces fois on est monté dedans
on l'a pas loupé cet avion il nous est
amené à détruire ce qu'on allait voir
est-ce que j'aurais quand même embarqué
si j'avais su qu'il allait m'amener vers
des Gorges du Verdon sans eau vers des
mers de glace sans glace vers une
Amazonie sans arbre alors oui c'est dur
c'est injuste c'est fatigant parce qu'il
faut dire que à coup de milliard on
s'est assuré de faire naître en nous le
désir de nous envoyer en l'air je
repense à cette publicité je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu vous aussi on la voyait
un moment donné dans le métro c'était la
publicité d'Air France quand on rentrait
d'une longue journée de cours ou de
boulot à travers les vitres salles du
métro c'était écrit en géant et va des
vous et bien sûr que j'avais envie d'y
être moi aussi dans cette sublime robe
rouge a volé dans les airs et puis à me
réveiller le lendemain aux Caraïbes bien
sûr qu'on a envie de bouffer le monde
pour être sûr de ne rien y louper
d'aller voir partout tout le monde pour
s'assurer de ne rien manquer mais cette
force du refus qui nous sauve je l'ai
trouvé en apprenant que ce désir n'était
pas le mien on s'évade de prison pas de
son quotidien
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut se
laisser bouleverser par son voisin vivre
mille aventure en partant stop en
Bretagne en vélo en Camargue en dormant
à la belle étoile dans les Pyrénées
qu'on n'aura pas assez d'une vie pour
découvrir l'Europe en train gravir tous
nos sommets visitez tous nos villages
que la beauté du monde est partout où on
réapprend à la voir la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il est encore temps d'atterrir
peut-être que l'urgence maman cèdent
rater l'avion merci Camille à signaler
la sortie de votre livre pour un
soulèvement écologique à lire de toute
urgence cette édité au Seuil pour
voyager autrement près de chez vous ce
livre escapade vers le vivant signé
Alice d'Orgeval aux éditions Gallimard
toujours chez Gallimard si vous voulez
aller plus loin à vélo en Europe c'est
pour vous Camille et pour aller pour
ceux qui souhaitent aller encore encore
plus loin tout en restant dans leur
canapé l'an 0 du tourisme de Jean Viard
et David Medioni aux éditions pour vous
Jean-François Rial
voilà j'espère que cette cour te bibliot
répondra à certaines de vos questions et
notamment à celle-ci comment éviter de
passer de l'usage du monde cher à
Nicolas Bouvier à l'usure du monde sur
ces mots je vous souhaite un très bel
été
[Musique]